the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
the technical topic for for today we
start right at the end a little bit
about tangent and normal unit vectors
and again just to recap that quickly and
then we're going to go on really a
review which by our review this is the
sort of stuff that for the most part I'm
sure you've seen in 801 physics and
other physics you've had before and
that's impulse linear momentum and
impulse so that'll be a quick review and
then the third subject is one that's
much deeper and this is angular momentum
and angular momentum with respect to
moving points which you probably haven't
encountered before so those are those
are the three topics for today well
let's get started so last time the piece
that I rushed a bit is this notion of
tangent and normal coordinates so I gave
this head this example you're driving
down the road you drunk or whatever and
when you're this point this point and
this point I'd like to know what the
accelerations are so I'll college one
two three and this curve y is of the
form some Y of some f of X and in this
case it's a sine K X and K is what's
known as wave number it's two pi over
the wavelength two PI over lambda and
the wavelength then is for example from
here to here
now the velocity I'm going to pick a
point here the velocity at any point we
know is just the tangent to the path so
this is the path and this is horizontal
so you drive it driving down the road
like this that's what we're trying to do
here the gravity is down into the board
doesn't really come in to into the
problem so the velocity at any point at
any time the vector we could describe as
a magnitude and a unit vector
we'll call UT which is the tangent unit
vector and at any instant in time it's
just aligned with the tangent to the
curve and the it's perpendicular partner
is a normal unit vector which it points
inward on the curve lissa bu n now we're
interested in accelerations so we'll
need to take a derivative of this but so
what I was gonna say but taken aside but
I won't so the acceleration vector we
have to take a derivative of this while
it's OB dot UT plus AV UT dot it's a
unit vector and we've encountered this
problem before because if this rotates
the unit vector has a nonzero derivative
because of its rotation and the this
derivative of the unit vector is given
by theta dot u and hat now what's theta
dot well on this curve at any instant
time here's you draw arrows today here's
your UT at any instant when you're
traveling along on a curve you are
going around a circle of some radius
will call ro so there's some radius of
curvature at any instant in time and
that radius of is you drive long in a
little time delta T you go forward an
amount Rho theta dot is the velocity at
which you're traveling tangent to the
curve this isn't it there's an angle in
here so in here there's some Delta you
advance some Delta Theta so R R Omega is
a velocity right so Rho theta dot is a
velocity and that gives you this
velocity magnitude B okay and we've gone
through I'm not going to go through that
little derivative that little argument
before but the the change in direction
of this unit vector UT when you go
forward a little bit is actually in word
UN by an amount Rho theta dot fighting
amount theta dot one times theta dot so
we've not going to do that piece of the
derivative before but here is this
derivative of the unit vector its theta
dot you end so if we substitute those
back in here we can get an expression
for our acceleration this is just the
seller ation along the path plus V theta
dot u N and then we need to take into
account the fact that we know that V it
met that magnitude of velocity the speed
in other words is Rho theta dot and that
means stay to dot is V over Rho so if we
plug that in up here then we get and it
a final expression for our acceleration
v dot UT plus V squared over Rho u N and
that V squared over Rho this is a this
is a centripetal acceleration term
you're going around a curve there's an
acceleration inward it's just like as we
did from polar coordinates from it comes
from rotating things well as soon as you
go around a curb you're going to
generate an acceleration that is of the
same kind but now we because you tend to
know speed it's easier to express it
this way when you're doing these tangent
normal problems and this is just the
acceleration along the path the usual
hit the gas pedal and speed up that's
this term okay so the piece that I
didn't have time to put up
last time which is in the book as is
this little derivative the derivation of
that it's one page in one of the early
chapters of the book how do you get Rho
and Rho when you hang up a Y as a
function of X there's just this formula
from mathematics from calculus that says
Rho is dy DX 1 plus dy DX quantity
squared to the three-halves power all
over the magnitude of D 2 y DX squared
and you just calculate these quantities
and plug them in so for y equals a sine
KX then dy DX it's a-okay cosine KX and
d2y DX squared is minus a K squared sine
KX so we now have these two quantities
we pick a value of exit which we want to
know the answer like point 1 so at Point
1 KX is PI over 2 right because sine is
a maximum X is lambda over 4 KX is PI
over 2 sine KX is 1 cosine KX 0 and so
we can calculate a row 1 + and dy DX the
derivative is cosine that's 0 so this
term in here is 0 this is to the
three-halves that's pretty easy to
this term down here d2y DX squared well
sine of KX is 1 so that's minus a K
squared but this is an absolute value
sign so this just turns out to be 1 over
a K squared and we'll plug in some
numbers I'm gonna let my lambda be 150
meters my amplitude here that I'm
swerving back and forth let's make that
5 meters
we need a that's all we need to get row
so row in this case works out to be a
hundred and fourteen meters so the
radius of curvature of this road that
I'm driving down at that that point
right at the peak in the curve is 114
meters so the acceleration that I'm
looking for a well it's V dot u T and if
I'm not accelerated we're not hitting
the gas pedal constant speed I'll let
that one be zero and the other one then
is V squared over Rho in the UN
direction and let's let V equal mmm I
have here in my example 20 meters per
second which is about 40 knots and
they're not is 15 percent more than a
mile per hour so it's somewhere about 45
miles an hour so typical road speed
driving down the road 20 meters per
second now you can plug in here you can
plug in here and you can find that the
acceleration
I work out here is three point five one
meters per second squared and in what
direction is it
what direction is that it's in the
normal direction to the inside of the
curve the outside curve inside
always to be inside that curve so these
tangent on this tangent normal
coordinates are really simple
coordinates that they're meant for a
particular kind of simple problem when
you know the path and it's just defined
the normal U n is positive always inward
to the center of the curve pointing
toward the center of rotation or that
radius of where your radius of curve is
always pointing at the origin of that
radius of your curve okay
so G's order of ten meters per second
squared so that's about a third of a G
would you third of G enough to notice
yeah absolutely you push it aside a car
if you do that okay all right so let's
little any questions about that I'm
going to move on next not I'm gonna move
on to linear impulse and momentum and
this would be a quick review because
this is consists of the physics the kind
of physics that you've done lots of
times we're going to hit it quickly and
then move on to angular momentum so we
know for a particle this is what Newton
told us you've got a particle here
that's some mass M we know for a partner
has some external forces on it we know
for a particle that the sum of these
external forces to vector sum is equal
to the mass times the acceleration for
the particle Newton's second law
and that's the mass times the derivative
of the velocity with respect to time
that's where we get acceleration so this
formula we can just rearrange the DTS a
little bit so the summation of the
forces DT is M DV and I want to
integrate these so if I integrate this
over time from some t1 to t2 this
equality says we're going to find some
change in velocity from v1 to v2 and
this is our imp this is kind of the
beginning of our impulse momentum
relationship we tend to call the
integration of forces over time impulse
and if you have a non zero impulse that
leads to a change in the linear momentum
okay so when you carry out some so the
writing this a little bit different way
you can do summation because these are
vectors and we have rules about vectors
you can bring the summation outside of
the integral so that this says that the
summation of the integral from t1 to t2
of these external forces is just M v2
minus M v1 because the integral in the
right hand side is really simple and
we'll finally state this in a way that
we most commonly use it moving this term
to the left so you start off with an
initial momentum M v1 you add to it the
summation of the impulses that you that
occur over time t1 to t2 of the external
forces and you get the final momentum M
v2
and this is the way you usually use the
formula so what happens if there's no
external forces that's that's where we
get the law of conservation of momentum
if there are no external forces on the
particle the momentum doesn't change in
MB one's got to be equal to mV to
so just a really trivial example drawing
for something that we've done before you
get the block sliding down the hill
draw your Freebody diagram
get friction got gravity get a normal
force and we'll set ourselves up with a
coordinate system aligned with the
motion we're interested in so this is an
inertial system X Y and we've done this
problem before so we said the summation
and we found out that the summation of
the forces in the x-direction or not
this is a good moment to take an aside
for a second this was a vector
expression but you can break it you can
implement it you can break it down into
its individual vector components so that
equation gives you four particles gives
you three sub equations one during the
x1 and the y1 and Z and you can use them
each independently so in this case we're
going to use to only need the X
component in order to do the problem so
the sum of the forces in the x-direction
now in this problem we which we had done
before is mg sine theta that component
of gravity pulling it down the hill
minus mu mg cosine theta and that's the
friction and none of these are functions
of time so that whole thing is just some
constant I just call it K all right so
the total forces on this system in the
x-direction is just some constant and
that makes this integral up your pretty
trivial to implement so now we can say
that M the one I'll just make it v 1x to
emphasize that integral from zero or t1
to t2 but I'm gonna let t1 be zero
usually makes it problems easier so
zero to T zero to T of K DT equals MV -
I can't write this morning in the X
direction and if V 1 X is zero starts
off at zero time and zero velocity when
you let it go to start with then you
just then this term will go away and we
just if implement this integral the
integral of K DT is K T right so this
says then that K T evaluated from zero
to some time that we want to know the
answer is M be two in the X direction
and so let's let T equal three seconds
you find out that V - X is three K over
m and in this problem then that looks
like three G sine theta minus mu cosine
theta so really trivial almost trivial
example it's not a hard example but it
emphasizes all of the key points in the
problem start off with a vector equation
you can apply it in any one of the three
vectors or three vector component
directions you integrate the forces the
sum of the forces on the object in that
direction over time and you applied the
impulse momentum formula and you get the
answer you can do that so that basic
step-by-step process is how you
basically most impulse momentum problems
are done and if there's no forces then
you have conservation or moment
okay so let's do there's that I this was
for particles
just a quick reminder we need to ask
ourselves as this apply to groups of
particles systems of particles well
remember that we said if you've got a
bunch of particles a system all of these
are the M eyes we've already figured out
that the total mass of the system times
the velocity of the center of mass is G
as my center of mass with respect to my
inertial frame so this is the momentum
of the system that was just the
summation of the individual m.i.b eyes
with respect to O and furthermore we
took a derivative of this so this is the
momentum of the system the time
derivative of the momentum should be the
external forces so that we were able to
by taking that derivative you get MT the
total mass times the G with respect to O
dot and that had better gives you be
equal to the summation of the external
forces on all the particles because you
can do it one particle of time and they
all each each of these particles has
forces you sum them all up you get these
forces and this is this allows you to
say that the sum of all of the external
forces on the system is equal to the
total mass of the system times the
acceleration of the center of mass so
this formula now can it looks very
similar to where we started with this
little derivation for a particle you can
now say that the summation this all
leads to the summation of the integral
from t1 to t2 all of these forces over
time gives you the change in the total
linear momentum of the system V G with
respect to O one - rather - VJ with
respect to O - the second one
so this is exactly the same kind of
formulation the change in the linear
momentum of the system is equal to the
integral of the forces on the system
over time so the impulse to the system
so you know what this allows you to do
problems that you might not have thought
about before so I think about something
like this I've got an old revenue a
Revolutionary War earlier period cannon
I can try to draw so here's my cannon
barrel and back in those days a little
better job here so we've got this cannon
sitting here and in the barrel you've
got a bunch of what's known as in the
old days known as grapeshot
so sometimes for kind of for
antipersonnel kind of stuff they would
just throw a whole bunch of metal and
junk into it but this imagine a bunch of
iron balls or lead balls or rocks or
whatever you want to put in there you
put a whole mess of them in here and you
have a charge you set it off and it
shoots them at the end of the gun I want
to know what's the reaction
what's the reaction force on the gun
how much what's that one that gun when
that charge goes off if you ever go if
you go down to the Constitution which is
the oldest commissioned warship in the
US Navy still afloat it's that I don't
know if any of you have seen it down
here in the dock in Chelsea was it built
around 1799 but when one of those when
they shot one of those guns the gun
would roll back several feet and get
dragged to a stop by a bunch of
restraining lines and then dragged back
up for another for another load so the
reaction force the force pushing back
these things usually sitting on wheels
could be pretty large let's take an
estimate of it so this is going to be a
relatively small gun the mass of the
total mass of a shot here times G is 10
pounds just 10 pounds of shot and gallon
of milk weighs 8 pounds so we're not
this isn't a very big very big load and
let's say that this barrel here from
here to here the acceleration length is
7 feet so that shots accelerated out the
barrel over a distance of 7 feet and it
has a muzzle velocity and exit velocity
of 700 feet per second our most guns
subsonic supersonic projectiles when
they come out of guns it's not about
that I would I'm just asking to see if
you have a feeling for speed how close
to the speed of sound is that
so speed of sound is about 1,100 feet
per second 340 meters per second so this
is order of Mach point-six or something
like that
something like 0.6 not 0.06 0.6 so about
60% of the speed of sound that's kind of
slow actually as guns go so the initial
velocity the shots just sitting there is
zero the final velocity is 700 feet per
second the average velocity which I'm
gonna need for a second because I'm just
making some estimates here the average
velocity average of zero plus 700 is 350
feet per second to do the reason I need
this is I need to estimate the delta T
how long does it take to get the shot
out of the barrel so distance equals
rate times time
right so the V average times delta T
equals seven feet at 350 feet per second
you find out delta T is about 0.02
seconds so it gets out the barrel pretty
quickly 0.02 seconds 20 milliseconds now
that powder when it goes off it's
putting a lot of forces on the shot so
of the total force on the shots 5,000
pounds what's the reaction force on the
cannon
so we're gonna apply a principle here
that we talked about earlier Newton had
three laws this is a group this is this
massive balls in there the hot exploding
gases are pushing them out the barrel
what must be the push of the same gas on
the cannon that's containing it equal
and opposite of Newton's third law right
so the reaction the reaction force that
we're looking for is minus the force
that it takes to get the shot out the
barrel okay
so force on the balls on the shot - the
reaction force and that's it stared
wrong okay so we're almost there but
just applying now this concept of
impulse and momentum so now we can say
the integral and this is the summation
you got a whole bunch of balls in there
they're all got forces on them but we're
treating the group of balls as a system
so we can we can use this notion of the
math total mass times the velocity of
the center of gravity to do this problem
so this is the force on all of these
little balls integrated over time it's
going to be the mass total of the balls
times the change in the velocity of the
center of gravity the final velocity
minus the initial velocity this is zero
okay we know this we know this so this
MT is the ten pounds over G we know this
is 700 feet per second we know that all
of this mounts up to
the force external on the group delta T
and this is the weight of the ball W
over G and this is 700 feet per second
that's 10 pounds divided by gravity
thirty two point one two and we need to
divide by delta T so the F external
force on the balls is W / g delta T
times seven hundred feet per second and
if you work out those numbers you get
ten thousand eight hundred and seventy
pounds now is this is an average force
right because we had delta T is the
length of time it took assuming we had
some one we assumed an average velocity
going down the barrel so the peak force
is probably higher than this and the
pressure the barrel probably isn't
constantly this actually isn't a bad
estimate if you know the muzzle velocity
which you could figure out probably from
the distance it goes and things like
that you can make this estimate so
10,000 pounds of reaction force is quite
a lot this is this is a dinky gun 10
this is 10 pounds of shot it's not much
so that's this is this is the force to
get the balls out the barrel if it's
positive what's the reaction force minus
10,000 870 and all through this I've
been doing this in a single vector
direction so I would have set up my
coordinate system like here's oh this is
the X Direction y direction so this is
obviously in the positive x-direction is
what I've lined up by positive
velocities and positive forces to be
so just a really simple way one of the
kind of ways in which you use this
notion of impulse and momentum but you
can use it to make estimates to okay and
if you ever fired a shotgun yeah any
kick right so what gauge shotgun did you
fire you no no okay okay 12-gauge
shotgun oh the the carriage is about
three quarters of an inch in diameter
and probably has a little mount of
powder in there amounts up to about that
much stuff but it can give you a bruise
in the shoulder if you don't hold it
right okay so that's what that's what
this is about
all right so this kind of a quick review
you've done lots of conservation of
momentum problems in your time the
homework set this this time has two or
three problems on it that are
conservation of momentum linear momentum
but now I want to move on to talking
about angular momentum and angular
momentum in a way in which you probably
haven't done angular momentum problems
before so anything about that last thing
on this
so mostly this I want you to read that
read that chapter I think it's chapter
15 first few sections of it are on
linear momentum the last few sections on
angular momentum go read them and just
work the problems that's where they
that's where you'll get most your
refresher is where is doing the practice
problems ok angular momentum
so we'll start with particle we're very
rapidly going to get two rigid bodies
now mo many times you've done angular
momentum problems before mostly
rotations about fixed axes so here's our
inertial frame fixed X Y and you have a
particle out here and it just has some
mass m and it has some total force on it
the force and this is the particle is
located at B here
so the force would be total force would
be just some vector
it also Strava lling with some velocity
at that instant in time so it has
momentum and the momentum is P of this
particle at B with respect to O and I'd
like to the extended expression then for
the angular momentum of this particle at
B with respect to O we have a position
vector here our Bo which we've used lots
of times right now is just the cross
product of the position vector with the
linear momentum
and that's just that's the definition of
angular momentum and I'm using a
lowercase H here so they're going to do
that to indicate single particles and I
use a capital H later on when we're
referring to rigid bodies so the angular
momentum of this particle with respect
to this point is given by that and
you've where you've used this before
then it's the derivative of H B with
respect to O DT is what's that remember
where does this give you the time to
write a change of the angular momentum
is the torque right and it's the torque
it's the sum of the torques applied on
that object with respect to the
coordinate system in which you're
computing the angular momentum so that's
you've used this formula many times and
in planar motion where you only have one
axis of rotation usually the z axis of
rotation you usually usually would write
this as AI theta double dot right in its
simplest form if it's a rigid body it
has a mass moment of inertia a times
theta double dot is equal to the sum of
the external torque so that's where
you've met this before but for the
moment this is just a particle let's
stick with a particle so the piece of
snoo here probably new for you is that
what if I want to know the angular
momentum with respect to another point
so here's a point a I'd like to compute
H of B with respect to a well that's our
B with respect to a cross P B with
respect to O and this is really easy to
forget the momentum is always calculated
with respect to your inertial frame
and that's why keeping this risk with
respect to and telling you what the
frame is is pretty important but we're
out here some arbitrary point computing
the karate cross product of the position
vector from this arbitrary point to this
moving mass and we're defining this is
just a definition defining the angular
momentum with respect to this point a as
R be a cross P the P with respect to O
and what I want to get to is now is the
torque on this system on this park
around this particle B with respect to a
it's the time rate of change of H B a
with respect to T but now it's a little
more complicated plus the velocity of a
with respect to O all vectors cross P V
with respect to O messy term I was
trying to think of an example where you
might want to do this
so imagine that you've got an arm which
can rotate you might be on a robot or
something like that and it has attached
to it another arm with a mass on it and
you've got a motor here which can make
this rotate and you're trying to design
the motor has to be able to put out a
certain amount of torque so this is oh
this is B this is a and you actually I
want to know the torque required in this
motor to drive this thing around but the
motor is here and it only cares about
what it feels so the torque at this
point to drive this thing but this whole
system is now in motion you'd have to
use this formula okay so there are
practical times when you'd like to be
able to be able to calculate something
like this
so there's a we're going to show you the
a very brief derivation of this and but
just so you could get a feeling for
where this comes from because there's a
couple of outcomes that are very
important to us
so the sum of the forces there at those
forces at B give you the time rate of
change of the momentum at B with respect
to O this is that momentum vector of our
particle okay and this FB this is a
total external forces acting on the
particle we know that's M single
particle times the velocity of that
certainly could be write times but
that's our familiar formula for F equals
MA all right so the time derivative the
linear momentum gives you this and the
torque of B with respect to a is our B a
cross times that this total I mean let
this just be a total vector I'll call it
f B it's a vector the torque with
respect to a is just RBA across this
total external force okay and that's our
B a cross the time derivative of P Bo
because the forces give us our just from
the time rate of change of the linear
momentum of that particle so I can say
it like this but now this there's just a
little vector identity for
products of vectors that I'm going to
take advantage of and I'll call this Q
so Q so Q is of the form and I'm going
to say Matt this is a quantity of vector
a and this is a quantity of vector time
derivative of the vector B it's a cross
DB DT so there's a little identity that
you can use it says a cross DB DT you
can you can alternatively write that as
the time derivative of a cross B - time
derivative of a cross B and if we're
good we're going to take advantage of
this and just re construct this formula
using this expression
so that says torque of B with respect to
a the time derivative of RBA cross p vo
- the derivative of r be a cross PBF so
we've just made this substitution down
here in terms of RBA and PBO
all vectors but we know that RBA from
all the previous work we've done is just
our BL minus r AO so the derivative of
RBA with respect to time
it's vb o - V yeah all right we're
almost there
we're almost there I'm gonna need
another board
this quantity here this is just H be a
this is the angular momentum of the
particle with respect to a it's just R
cross B you recall
so then we can rewrite this expression
for the torque as the time derivative of
H of B with respect to a that's because
of what I did point it out there and now
this is minus VB minus VA Oh cross P Bo
so P of B with respect to O is just M
velocity of B with respect to O right so
V Bo cross PB o gives you what nothing
get you zero because they're in parallel
they go in there exactly they're in the
same direction so this you only get a
nonzero piece out of this minus times
minus gives you a plus and you end up
with
and that's what we set out to find I
said this is where I was trying to get
and now we're there you know the
importantly there's a couple of special
cases of this this can be kind of a
nuisance term to have to deal with lots
of times you'd like to be able to get
rid of it and just be able to go back to
that old reliable formula that work is
time rate of change of angular momentum
so there are two obvious almost maybe
obvious conditions in which this will go
away what's the most obvious one
something what you say well yeah this
just this term presumably not this guy
if this is zero
it's just back to our old familiar
formula that's one case the case one but
now actually this actually this is a
really important result because a can be
anywhere as long as it's not moving and
so this allows you to do things talked
about rotations about fixed axes that
aren't at the center of mass right so if
you have a fixed axis of rotation and
something going around it that's what
this allows you to do okay that's one
case so this is tip isn't it this will
soon get to rigid bodies rigid bodies
would be exactly the same formulas and
you can have a rigid body now that it's
not rotating about its center but
rotating maybe about its end
I guess that formula applies if the
velocity of that axis about which it's
rotating about what you're computing
this is not moving then you can just use
you don't have to deal with that messy
term so this is one case in which this
term goes away the other case is if this
velocity is parallel to the direction of
the momentum and there's a really useful
time that that happens so also this
formula is true case two is when the a/o
is parallel to PBO the direction they're
going in the same direction now that
happens when a is guaranteed to be true
if a is at the center of mass because
the momentum is defined as the mass of
the object times the velocity of its
center of mass right even for rigid
bodies
so this is true when a is and I'll call
it G at the center of mass so this gives
us an another really important
generalization
that we'll use that we make great use of
in dynamics
and that says that the torque with
respect to the center of mass is time
rate of change of H with respect to G
now I'm not going to go I did the proof
to give this went through this little
proof just for a particle that by
summing a bunch of particles and kind of
going through all the summations as we
did to prove the center of mass formula
you can show this allows you to very
quickly show that this formulation is
also true for rigid bodies so your way
you say it for rigid bodies
is that the sum of the torques about
with respect to some point for a rigid
body is H now capital H H dot with
respect to a plus the velocity of a with
respect to O cross P and now I'm going
to say gee it's center of mass senator
gravity with respect to O so the same
statement for a rigid body this is the
torque with respect to some point a
which can be moving now even
accelerating is the time rate of change
of the angular momentum with respect to
a of that rigid body plus VA o cross pgo
okay and again when would this take what
would this messy second term go to zero
when the velocity of a is zero
fixed axis rotation or when this is
parallel to that which is true for the
center of mass always so the same two
special cases apply for rigid bodies
when velocity of a with respect to O
equals zero or when the velocity of a
with respect to O is parallel to the P
and the kiss spec the most important
case of that is always true
that's always the case and then these
one you can say this then the torque
with respect to a is d H respect to ADT
no second terms and it's those kinds of
this you've applied generally in your
physics like in 801 you've used formulas
like this a lot done problems either
with respect to the center of mass so
objects running doing things like that
you'll do the torque formulas with
respect to the center of mass or when
you have things that are pinned to
points and rotate about fixed axes then
you use the other formulation where it's
with respect to a non moving point so
this is fixed axis rotation
okay all right so that's kind of the dry
derivation part of it I'm going to see
if I can find an example here okay this
is quite a bit like a number of the
homework problems
so I've got a carnival ride got a bar
and it's got a seat out here you're
riding in it all right so you taking
this ride it's rotating this is some
fixed axis here and they you have a
fixed coordinate system your o X Y Z and
then you'd probably have some rotating
coordinate system with the point a fixed
here at the axis of rotation and this is
going the what's what's unusual about
this right not only can go around and
around but the arm can go in and out so
it might take a path in words like if
you pull the arm in as you're going
around what are the forces that you feel
in the ride ok so this is my point B out
here it's where the person's at have
some mass m and let's let for now first
case
they did not let that be constant a
constant angular trade here yours theta
and our dive alright
now you already know quite a bit about
things like this what forces if you're
riding in that bucket what forces do you
think you would feel or I should say it
and more carefully there will be
accelerations that you feel in that
bucket you'll feel like horses on you
but what are the accelerations that you
will feel you expect to be if you're
riding in it I'm here one here so
they'll be centripetal acceleration
right everybody agree with that have
anything else it's gonna be some
Coriolis because our dot is not zero
right it's changing in position but when
the length of the arm it's something
rotating at constant speed changes what
momentum changes
angular for sure how about lynnium of it
yeah it's changing too because our cross
P is angular momentum so both linear and
angular momentum are changing as this
radius gets longer or shorter and if
they if that angular momentum changes it
takes torque to drive it and so we ought
to be able to use the formulas that
we've just derived to calculate
something about the torques required to
make this happen and the forces on the
writer
okay so we'll treat this one as a
particle so H the angular momentum of
that of the rider out here at B with
respect to O it's gonna be our bo cross
P and in this problem I'll use polar
coordinates pretty easy this is a planar
motion problem it's confined to the XY
plane and rotation and Z so polar
coordinates are pretty convenient so
this should look like radius R R hat
cross and the the linear momentum of
this is the mass times r dot R hat
that's the extension rate but it also
has velocity in the theta hat direction
R theta hat so this is P with respect to
O M V and this is the rate this is the
are crossed into it
now our our hat cross our hat gives us
zero so you only get a single turn out
of this and you get an R cross they are
hats cross theta hat positive K so this
looks like plus M R squared
they did not yeah that's my H B oh now I
would that's my first piece that wanted
to get that's the a part that's fine the
angular momentum so this is a B I want
to know the tour well which formula can
we use are we allowed to use do we have
to account for that second term no why
yeah the velocity of the point about
which we're computing the angular
momentum and therefore the torques is
not moving so you only have to deal with
the first term so the torque required to
move that particle of B with respect to
O it's just the time rate of change D by
DT of H B with respect to O and that's d
by DT of M R squared theta dot k hat so
what are the constants in this
expression so we don't have to worry
about their derivatives its K hat change
length no change direction no they did
not
does it change in this problem no we
fixed it we said it was arbitrarily
started off saying that we'll just let
theta dot be constant R though is
changing so time derivative of this
particular one only and we have to only
have to deal with the are actually I'll
prefer get that for a second cuz I want
to get both terms and it will let it be
a zero so this time derivative then when
you work it out
all right
the derivative of the art term gives you
two m r r dot theta dot k hat and i'll
just go ahead and forget for a minute
that I said that's constant let's get
the other term that might be there that
term gives us M R squared theta double
dot okay
this term comes from what we'll we'll
find is the Coriolis one and this is
from what we'd call the oil Arian
acceleration this torque must the torque
get this up a little higher we should be
able to write as some R cross F right
and so the R cross F terms this will be
from the Coriolis force and this would
be from that or lower Alerian force so
this will look like our our hat crossed
I'm just factoring this back out into
its cross products our our hat cross 2m
r dot theta dot in the theta hat
direction plus r theta double dot in the
theta hat direction
so there's two terms in this torque
expression they come from our cross two
force terms the first force term is what
we know to be the Coriolis force and the
second force term I'm missing an M here
our M theta double dot theta hat that's
the force that it takes to if the thing
we're accelerating
just to accelerate that ball theta
double dot takes that ticks off force
you do these cross products R cross
theta hat gives you K R cross theta hat
gives you K
it all comes out in the right directions
and now to do the problem we had we said
oh yeah but this one's zero so we'll let
this term go to zero or left with a
single term
and if we plugged in some numbers let's
just see if how this works out and this
we know it just are across the coriolis
well let's let em let em be a hundred
kilograms and our be five meters our dot
zero point four meters per second all
kind of perfectly reasonable dimensions
and theta dot equals three radians per
second so 2pi radians per second means
it goes around once once a second right
this is a little less than half our ever
second yeah probably yeah good catch
gotta have an R in it because that our
comes from here right so I had Coriolis
force written down but not that are you
have to multiply it by so now we get if
you plug in all of these numbers let's
see if it see if it's a ride you could
survive I actually computed the Coriolis
force first it's just uh I think it's
just interesting to get a physical
feeling for how and whether or not you
can feel these forces so the Coriolis
force is just everything but they are 2m
r dot theta dot so if you calculate that
you get 240 Newton's and R times that
the torque
five times that about 1200 Newton meters
and the acceleration I know he gets
acceleration well F of Cour Coriolis
force is some mass times an acceleration
so we can solve from that 240 Newton's
the mass the acceleration of the system
L acceleration of a B with respect to
240 Newton's divided by a hundred
kilograms 2.4 meters per second squared
and what's that in G's yeah that quarter
of a G and again would you feel that so
now you're writing this so now you're
riding in the bucket right let's say
it's just spinning around the arms not
going in and out at all so you're riding
in it what do you what force would you
feel would you feel any forces pushing
you into your seat constant speed R dot
zero
somebody out there would you feel any
force if you're going around and around
in this thing sitting in the seat okay
what's it come from centripetal
acceleration right all right so and that
is in what direction
acceleration is inward what would you
actually feel you you'd feel at this but
if this seat could swing out so you're
facing in you'd feel like you're being
thrown out in your seat right because
you have to have a force on you to make
that acceleration happen the
acceleration is inward the force had
better be pushing you in word so it's
pushing on your back if you're looking
in going around so that's the you know
the forgotten term form but you know to
put the astronauts in a centrifuge right
spin around to see if they can take high
G's okay that's that that's the G the
inward high G acceleration due to the
centripetal acceleration maybe going a
circle but now not only are you gonna
feel that but now you start changing the
length of the arm and if you change it
or if you change our dot and make it
positive so the arm is getting longer
and we made this point four meters per
second so it's moving out you know about
like that it's not real fast but it's
gonna create a quarter of a G
acceleration on you and and if our dots
positive which direction is that
acceleration
I was careful we walked all the way
through this acceleration is positive
but in what direction for Coriolis theta
hat positive theta hat so it's in the
direction of increasing theta so this
one is perpendicular to the arm right
and this is this is the you know on my
ping-pong ball in here the force that
actually causes it to speed up is partly
Coriolis and partly or layer and if I
can make this go at constant speed the
force that drives that the force that
actually speeds that up is there going
out it's the Coriolis force the normal
one so if you were on this ride you'd be
feeling about a quarter of a
perpendicular to the arm he'd be feeling
another force inward that's the sin trip
due to caused by the centripetal
acceleration so you'd be feeling both of
them how BIG's the centripetal
acceleration sort of like our Omega
squared right RS 5 Omega is 3 3 squared
is 9 times 5 9 times 5
45 divided by 10 4 and 1/2 years you
wouldn't notice the core oh you wouldn't
notice the Coriolis very much it'd be
kind of is be kind of a tough tough ride
on the on that side of things
ok so we've done that you've seen a
simple application pretty
straightforward application of using
time derivative of angular momentum to
calculate torques so homework again
there's a couple problems you know very
similar to the one I just did things
going around circus rides that kind of
stuff so have a good weekend see on
Tuesday
you